[Musique]
dernier vol ce matin
venance du brésil les liaisons aériennes
sont maintenant suspendus sur décision
des autorités
et on ne peut pas suspendre c'est ce que
disait le miz transports lundi le
lendemain voilà que le polémiste dit le
contraire
yat-il incohérences de seule cohérence
que je connais c'est la cohérence
solitaire c'est une décision qui pour
une partie des médecins va
considérablement jouer dans la
limitation de la propagation du variant
brésilien et de vraies inquiétudes sur
le variant brésilien on suspend les vols
en provenance du brésil ça me paraît la
sagesse il est encore trop tôt pour
constater une pleine efficacité de ces
mesures au niveau national j'ajoute que
le pic d hospitalisation n'a pas encore
été atteint cela signifie que nous avons
encore devant nous des jours très
difficiles avant qu'on sache donc dès
que moi il ya eu un exercice de
simulation de la pandémie coronavirus
avec les puissances privées des géants
mondiaux des laboratoires big pharma big
data blick finances et ils ont ils ont
simulé la pandémie ça veut dire qu'il
s'y attendait alors je dis pas du tout
que je suis pas complète
le danemark est devenu le premier pays à
renoncer définitivement au vaccin
astrazeneca les autorités sanitaires ont
annoncé l'arrêt dessous une
administration raison d'amener
impossible donc avec de rares cas de
thrombose
je vous rappelle qu'il ya les etats-unis
ont décidé de marquer une pause dans
l'utilisation du vaccin
johnson & johnson et la france elle
comptait beaucoup sur ce nouveau sérum
pour les plus de 55 ans elle devait en
recevoir 600 mille doses ce mois ci puis
montée en puissance pour arriver à 8
million cent mille personnes vaccinées
par janssen en juin l'agencé européenne
des médicaments qui se réunit
aujourd'hui même et qui va nous faire
part d'éventuelles recommandations dans
la journée j'espère que dans la journée
et nous avons reçu conformément aux
objectifs les 200000 première dose de
johnson qui ne sont pas encore
administrés sont des profiteurs de
guerre il de profiteurs de pandémie ils
profitent ces gens-là ce capitalisme
surveillance de la pandémie pour
prospérer et pour installer ce qui plaît
au pouvoir politique
quand un pouvoir est faible le
troll total la société disciplinaire
comme de soissons ça m'a été refusée
comme tout le reste au niveau national
je me suis retourné vers les russes j'ai
vu l'ambassadeur de russie j'ai vu le
land allemand de la bavière qui est le
plus puissant d'allemagne et j'ai fait
une précommande de 500 mille doses de
spoutnik l'état a évalué combien va lui
coûter cette crise est le fameux quoi
qu'il en coûte prononcé à de nombreuses
reprises une dépense publique estimée à
420 milliards d'euros pour 2020 2021 et
cirque olivier duhamel a une relation
avec son beau fils qui est un jeune
adolescent et ces criminels série donc
ya pas de blague donc pourquoi
cherche-t-il à nuancer vous allez voir
on mélange tout dans ses dépenses
il est évidemment tout ce qui est lié
aux mesures d'urgence soutient les
entreprises le chômage partiel etc
mais c'est intègre aussi la flambée du
coût des dépenses sanitaires les
campagnes de vaccination qui coûte très
cher et ça intègre le plan de relance
qui va permettre de relancer la machine
il suffit de quelques autres j'ai
répondre tout de suite la has a commencé
oui ça a commencé l'émission a commencé
on est à l'antenne depuis cinq minutes
mais ton nom restera associé à la plus
grande escroquerie financière de
l'histoire bernard madoff est décédé en
prison aux états unis il avait 82 ans et
purgeait une peine de 150 ans
d'emprisonnement et les réseaux sociaux
c'est la culture de l'extrait on prend
un morceau et on dit regardez ce qu'il a
dit c'est le complice des pédocriminels
les cas je ne suis pas le conflit je ne
suis le complice de rien du tout